the largest gathering of the film
industry since the start of the pandemic
is underway this weekend the normally
star-studded affair
at the venice film festival is more
subdued this year with mass celebrities
socially distant audiences and no crowds
overlooking the red carpet
the venice film festival is seen as a
launching pad for the next wave of
movies
but a recent discovery is shedding light
on the earliest days of filmmaking
adriana diaz has this story
olivia babler's painstaking work
preserving films at the chicago film
archives
is usually routine that's a film i
probably spend
75 percent of my time peeling tape off
of things and trying to decipher bad
handwriting
but sometimes lightning strikes
she uncovered this 1923 midwestern
murder mystery
the first degree this is a film about
sheep farming
and black male and there's a villain
with a great mustache and there's a
great dog when during the pandemic she
finally had time for long neglected
reels that had come from a basement in
peoria illinois
it was thought to be lost forever like
75
of other silent films in the film world
this is a pretty big deal
there's a lot of folklore about lost
films
there's something can i say sexy yeah
it's pretty sexy to find something like
this there is
no reason this movie should have
survived most silent films have
succumbed to decay
or were destroyed by their own studios
says filmmaker and film historian jim
hemphill
these things were disposable to them
they didn't understand the movie's value
as cultural artifacts
they're not just about what they're
about they are
reflections of their time which means
they were often censored
perhaps why this copy is missing a title
screen that had justified murder
which was criticized in early reviews
finding this film
makes me wonder what archives would find
if they had the resources
and the time and the money that they
need and that they deserve
before these time capsules are lost
forever for cbs this morning saturday
adriana diaz chicago is that what we all
wonder
if we had the time the resources what we
could find you forget how much was lost
i know so interesting